[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur le Maire sur Moïse madame
messieurs les élus du conseil municipal
d'Apatou
monsieur le Président de l'Association
des fêtes d'un Patou et j'oubliais
monsieur le responsable du RSMA mesdames
Messieurs chers habitants d'Apatou je
souhaite d'abord remercier Monsieur le
Maire Moïse Edwin ainsi que Monsieur
Rozon Goubin président de l'association
des fêtes pour l'invitation à ce vin
d'honneur à l'occasion du lancement de
festivités patronales dès que j'ai reçu
l'invitation j'ai confirmé ma présence
car en tant que lui national ces
festivités sont l'opportunité de
maintenir les liens avec les élus et la
population et d'ailleurs il y a un an
j'étais à vos côtés c'est aussi
l'occasion pour bon nombre de nos
compatriotes de converger vers d'autres
communes afin de connaître notre
diversité ethnique culturelle
gastronomique et géographique c'est un
moment de cohésion à la fois communale
mais aussi territorial
c'est toujours avec un immense plaisir
que je visite nos communes la Guyane est
si belle si vaste pour moi qui sillonne
depuis des années notre territoire j'ai
toujours cette sensation d'être un peu
plus une exploratrice tant il y a des
choses à découvrir que cela soit sur le
littoral ou dans l'Hexagone j'évite
toujours mes différents interlocuteurs à
venir chez nous afin de découvrir nos
richesses être un Patou aujourd'hui
c'est célébrer votre commune avec son
histoire sa population mais aussi
partager votre culture si singulière qui
est un des fondements de notre réalité à
partout comme une bougie naguée peut
être fière de ce qu'elle apporte à notre
identité je sais que souvent vous vous
sentez oublier quand il s'agit d'évoquer
cet ensemble qui forme l'identité
guyanaise sentiment souvent fondés et
qui persiste avec l'isolement et les
difficultés du quotidien cette fête
patronale est donc l'opportunité pourra
pas tout de diffuser sont si riches
patrimoine culturels et nous d'apprendre
avec vous chers à patoucia je crois aux
devoirs de transmission et je sais qu'il
a encore un sens sur ces rives du fleuve
maudite notre pays traverse un moment
difficile et beaucoup s'interrogent sur
son avenir mon souhait c'est que
l'aiguille à naisses s'inspirent de nos
communes de l'intérieur ou comme ici à
Apatou on remarque une générosité on
remarque une tranquillité je dirais même
l'innocence d'une société en paix qui
manque quelquefois dans les grands
centres urbains j'ai ma répéter dans mes
nombreuses interventions que la Guyane
se relèvera dans l'unité de sa
population et de ses élus mais aussi par
un retour de certaines valeurs comme le
respect et l'autorité c'est pour ces
deux raisons d'ailleurs que je souhaite
le rétablissement du service militaire
obligatoire afin de redonner à notre
jeunesse le sens du civisme
sens de civisme qui est très important
pour la paix et la cohésion de nos
communes nous savons les défis auxquels
sont confrontés à Patou et les communes
de l'intérieur avec une démographie
soutenue et des services publics sous
pression Monsieur le Maire vous pouvez
compter sur moi fait d'accompagner votre
commune sur les différents dossiers au
niveau national je vous remercie encore
une fois pour l'invitation et je
souhaite à toutes et à tous une belle et
joyeuses fêtes pas trop dingue merci
beaucoup